i think we might
make a start councillors and it's my
pleasure to welcome you along to this
extraordinary meeting of council we have
two items on the agenda but before we
begin i'll just call for any apologies
and we have
three that i'm aware of we have
councillor bulger
uh council dixon and also councillor
grant
would somebody like to move that those
apologies be sustained please
councillor mcta now signature councillor
phillips all those in favor please say
aye
against the motion is carried so
i'm moving on to our first item on the
agenda
the adoption of our 2021 30
long-term plan a significant piece of
work that has taken
a long time to work through to work
through with the auditors particularly
and get to a result that we have so
we have a memo before us from the chief
financial officer and i'm just going to
ask lunai if you'd like to make some
comments to this before i open it for
discussion with council
okay thank you your worship and through
your worship um
yes the the long term plan has been um
quite an intensive process this year and
we are pleased to be at this point where
we can look to look to adopt
the key points i'd like to like to raise
are around
the changes from the deliberate from the
consultation document
those being the grants that the council
has
agreed upon with regards to act of
southland
the reserve the twenty-five thousand
dollars for the reserves
budget or parks and reserves for the
mountain bike track um
the inclusion of twenty thousand dollars
towards cultural training and tikanga
um and it's been spread over two years
there's been a couple of other
minor things that have happened through
that time as well and between
the consultation document and today waka
katahi announced their
proposed funding for the next three
years and that resulted in a decrease in
funding for gore district council
because it was significant we had to
re-forecast our numbers um and this has
had an impact
on on the resulting
rates increase the there's another a
couple of other
things that we put that popped up and we
looked at the funding for district plan
and district plan
and the initial consultation document we
had it funded out of rates
and rates increases rather than actually
i've loan funded over a number of years
district plan has benefits to the
community over a number of years and
therefore
and consistency with past practice we
have now loan funded which has again
helped decrease the the rates increase
and the third thing was
around the otama tama water scheme some
information was provided late in the
piece
that wasn't previously available to me
and we we worked through and we've now
got
a combination of funding between
rates for use or user pays and also out
of reserves
so the combined effort of those three
items have resulted in an
average of 6.42 increase for the for the
district which
um is a lot more palatable than our 8.22
we'd initially hoped for
the other the other item that we should
highlight at this point is also the
unbalanced budget
so in two of our 10 years we have what
is called an unbalanced budget
now that what this is is where we don't
raise enough income to cover
all of our expenses this was a conscious
decision
it's not out by much it's out by about
three hundred thousand one year and 125
or 180 000
second year this is a conscious decision
because we were putting a 6.42
increase in our first year we didn't
want those subsequent two years to also
be above five percent and reach our cap
so um we are confident that in
the movements within projects and timing
of expenses that this will be absorbed
in any way but we do have to um accept
that the
or adopt that there's going to be a
proof of an unbalanced budget
i'm happy to take further questions well
thank you lanay and and i'll open it up
for
discussion shortly but i just want to
say thank you for the the time and the
effort
that you and your team have put into
getting us to this point
in my time as mayor it's probably the
the rate setting long-term plan process
that has been
one of the most challenging and it's
been back and forth back and forth
a number of times and to get it to the
point we are now
i find is really pleasing from from your
perspective
and also from as and while
it is 5.42 6.42 is
above where we had predicted it uh it is
certainly
quite a bit lower than the 8.22
that we were looking at uh two or three
weeks ago
so so thank you for that
mr chief executive do you want to make
any comment before we open that to
counsellors yeah thank you worship i
just
endorsed your comments and the uh
lornae's comments that she's eloquently
put forward to you about the final
result
i think it needs to be put in
perspective too that
you can't underestimate the effect that
the floods followed by
covert 19 and the lockdown took in terms
of our planning time
that really did erode into it and so we
were always
uh on the back foot a little bit that
coupled with
and laurene's introduction to the
organization in june
and then you have the very exacting
audit process that was used this year
has certainly ramped up the time
required
to actually deliver a completed plan
so we'll certainly reflect on that when
we um have our
usual post-mortem review but i think
the council can be satisfied that when
you
calculate both the proposed rate
increase this year
uh on top of the 2.84
of last year you are still under
comfortably
under the 10 threshold you've set
by 5 caps year on year
so given the the environment we're
working within
um i would submit to you that's a pretty
comforting place to be uh given that
we had some fairly stiff challenges
facing us over the last few months
so all in all we worship lessons to be
learned
relieved that we've now got to this
point as paul mccartney saying it's a
long unwinding road that leads us to
your door
we're now at your door and hopefully
you can open it and then we can walk
through and
look at an environment post 2021
ltp adoption thank you steve
okay councillors um open for your
comment
and or adoption
councillor reed thank you your worship
yeah i'd just like to reiterate
thanks to lornae and for all the hard
work i'm assuming that the 6.42
is also including that 1 that we were
instructed to do by the audit is
auditors correct through worship um that
is correct um inflation has been
included in our first year and across
all ten years of our plan
in line with the auditor's direction
thank you
thank you
councillors any other comment are
councillor davis
thank you so you're moving
both recommendations right
thank you so we've got to move it over
secondary for that
councilor mcphail thank you
any further discussion on the plan
council grant thank you worship
just one just one thing i thought that
could be added if possible if if
everyone else has an agreement on just
on page six for the council for you
you have a photograph of the counselors
with no names
there are three three brand new
councillors uh this term
and councillors mick dao um
councillor grant and councilman who fail
and
some people may not know them so i was
just wondering if it would be
applicable to put names on that page
yeah uh look i think that's something
we'll take on board i'm not sure i think
that possibly was an oversight somewhere
along the line
but take that on board
okay um any other comment council match
to now
so can i ask you to come into the
lorna what's the plan there three three
russia the plan is to have it paid off
over ten years
it's in the it's in the model to be paid
off over 10 years
okay right any other comment question
if not we have a motion before us which
i'm going to put all those in favor
please say aye
against the motion is carried thank you
councillors so
following on from that decision we need
to
move a rates resolution and
a fairly long series of recommendations
that need to be
taken into account here so
lorna do you want to make any comment on
this i think it's reasonably
self-explanatory but
is there anything that needs to be
explained at this point in time we'll go
for questions
um i'm happy just to go for questions
and take it as read
okay councillors it's open for
discussion
and or question and or recommendation
hopefully everybody's had time council
davis thank you
um so move do i have a second off of
that councillor
heisted thank you i'll put that motion
all those in favor please say i against
the motion
is carried thank you councillors well
that's probably one of our more
important meetings we've had
in the last three years and probably one
of the shortest i'd have to say
so um but behind that short meeting
goes an awful lot of work and time and
effort and blood sweat and tears to be
honest
to get us to to this point so
congratulations once again to the team
that have put this together
and congratulations to the council for
the input along the way and with that
there's no further business on the
agenda that i'm aware of so i'll declare
the meeting closed and thank you for
your attendance